what advice would you give to young
people today
thinking about their career about their
life whether it's in mathematics
uh poetry or hot dog eating contest
and you know i have kids so this is
actually a live issue for me right i
actually it's a it's not a phonics room
and i actually do have to give
advice to two young people all the time
they don't listen but i still give it
um you know one thing i
often say to students i don't think i've
actually said this to my kids yet but i
say
to students a lot is you know you come
to these decision points
and everybody is beset by self-doubt
right is like not sure like what they're
capable of like not sure
what they're what they really want to do
i always i sort of tell people like
often when you have a decision to make
um one of the choices is the high
self-esteem choice
and i always thought make the high
self-esteem choice make the choice sort
of take yourself out of it and like
if you didn't have those you can
probably figure out what the version of
you
feels completely confident would do and
do that and see what happens and i think
that's often like pretty good
advice that's interesting sort of like
uh
you know like with sims you can create
characters like create
a character of yourself that lacks all
the self-doubt
right but it doesn't mean i would never
say to somebody you should just go have
high self-esteem yeah you shouldn't have
doubts no you probably should have
doubts it's okay to have them
but sometimes it's good to act in the
way that the person who didn't have them
would act um that's a really nice way to
put it
yeah that's a that's a like from a third
person perspective
take the part of your brain that wants
to do big things what would they do
that's not afraid to do those things
what would they do
yeah that's that's really nice that's
actually really nice way to formulate it
it's very practical advice you should
give it to your kids
you